[Music]
this is America and in American high
school if you're not hot you need
something else to get pocket no birdie
told me you're having a party party I
don't know what party you're talking
about oh my god talk about the small of
Fame you're the only boy in school with
no tallies next to your name are you
saving yourself for marriage No are you
wrong asexual because I have a pamphlet
for that it looks like Thor but like
ethnically ambiguous look I want to like
spongebob those SquarePants he changed a
lot got like really attractive really
really hot honey
you're good-looking too he's okay he's
like a five six top the park is a great
place to learn to talk to girls
oh my god Wow it's crazy seeing you guys
again officer I don't understand the
misunderstand
well her point is that I was saying we
weren't stalking them it just looked
exactly like we were wearing the
jeggings I caught you
of course I wouldn't man Jesus Christ
[Music]
what are you wearing clothes this is an
ABC party or anything but clothes
[Applause]
you think a convention people's carpets
just bizarre fly
[Music]
I'm so glad I got into education
oh my god I'm so sorry about last night
I know right so much fun we should
totally hang out again
[Music]
you